just a few hours ago we heard the 911  calls in the amari nicholson murder case  for the first time  omaree's mother's boyfriend is accused  of killing the two-year-old  amari's mother taylor called  her young 911 went missing and she told  a dispatcher that terrell rhodes the man  accused of killing amari  had told her a family member on the  other side of the family came to the  apartment  and took him here's a portion of that  phone call  ma'am who has your child i don't know  uh i was my boyfriend said that a lady  was knocking on the door this morning at  six  and said that she was my baby daddy's  sister  and said that uh she was there to pick  him up that everything was already  pre-pre-arranged and  i spoke to nobody so  they came in and took him and ran out  the door with him  and so i don't know if it is his sister  if it's some  a total stranger i don't know so to hear  both of those 911 calls you can head to  8newsnow.com brian